I want to talk about a story I did
yesterday where I told you about
students at the University of California
Berkeley had a day of protest to demand
the creation of additional safe spaces
for transgender and not white students
and during the protest I told you
yesterday that there was a sort of human
chain formed which was used to prevent
white and some Asian students from
getting to class but they would
interrupt the human chain to allow black
and Hispanic students to get to class
there has been a sort of counter
narrative to this now which argues that
it wasn't actually that white students
were being blocked and non white
students were being allowed the position
is that everybody was being blocked from
getting to class except for students
with disabilities but the reason that it
looked like the chain was interrupted
for the non-white students is because
the non-white students were actually
joining the chain the human chain as
opposed to just trying to get through it
and go to class let me give you a quote
from a recent article that was published
about this and we'll take a look at what
it says many news outlets reported that
activists who were part of the protests
refused passage to white students
attempting to pass through say their
gates but did not prevent minority
students from crossing Xavier said this
claim is false quote the students of
color were actually trying to join the
line in support people just didn't know
what they were looking at we turned away
everyone who came no matter what race or
ethnicity they were except for people
with disabilities according to campus
spokesperson Adam Ratliff campus
representatives have examined the
situation and spoken with eyewitnesses
including police officers and determined
that race did not play a role in the
protesters interactions with people who
attempted to pass through others have
emailed me saying David this is damage
control and it's obvious from the video
that those non-white students being let
through the chain we're not joining they
were just going to class I sort of think
it's not the most relevant thing you
know yesterday when we talked about this
Rachel I pointed out that it's sort of
ironic to use a sort of race-based
discrimination to protest race-based
discrimination but I think the bigger
picture is to discuss what is this
protest meant to achieve and number two
this approach likely to bring about the
change that protesters want and I think
that's really the key question where I
know not everybody in the audience
agrees with me on this I don't see this
type of protest achieving anything
particularly when seventy-five percent
of the incoming freshman class last year
at UC Berkeley was already not white
right I mean I never really understood
those type of tactics in terms of kind
of community protests I really it's kind
of like if you're using violence against
violence I don't ever think that really
works but it's interesting because at
Brandeis this was after after I
graduated it was inspired by the
everything that was going on at
University of Missouri with the hashtag
concerned students a bunch of students
at Brandeis ended up taking up the
office of the interim president Lisa
Lynch and they had this whole list of
demands
because of the lack of racial diversity
saying that they wanted to increase the
amount of black faculty to 10% and they
wanted to have a curriculum that was
more focused on racial diversity and
they also wanted to have diversity
workshops and I think that that type of
protest which ended up actually being
I'm pretty successful I don't know what
type of changes had been implemented but
I heard that there had been a lot of
positive feedback after they had taken
place that seemed more effective because
it was organized they had a list of
demands as opposed to kind of staging
something to make a statement
not to mention that they're actually
there they were protesting someone who
had the power to make changes and in the
administration as opposed to
inconveniencing the students who are
probably they're stressed out about
exams debt-ridden because of how
expensive colleges at this point did you
have any experiences at Suffolk Pat with
any of this type of stuff this sort of
thing probably couldn't happen at
Suffolk University because the campus is
more spread out it's more urban so you
can't really block people off from
entering to class yeah but I mean these
students are paying so much money you
think they could just protest somewhere
else and and still get their message
across yeah and I think more effectively
if you're actually protesting in a way
that it specifically is noticeable to or
conspicuous to those who were in the
administration rather than all students
I've said it before I said it about
black lives matter at the Dartmouth
library where students were quietly
trying to study for midterms or finals I
just would look at it from a pragmatic
point of view and I just don't think
this is going to achieve what anybody
wants it to achieve if there
even something unified that is sought
but what what about the protests we
recently talked about I think it was
abortion and it was in it was an Iceland
or the no Poland Poland Poland Poland
yeah so what about that that seemed like
it was I don't know not largely just
organized but it seemed to be more along
the lines of making a statement and that
ended up being successful in and of
itself though it doesn't actually appear
in other words the legislation had
already been suspended at the time that
the protests had started and I'm not a
protest don't work guy I'm just talking
about let's be really specific and
deliberate in terms of what it is that
we're protesting who were protesting and
how we're doing it good point I think
that in this particular case though the
targets were not the right people no
time for voicemail today on the bonus
show we will talk about Americans
spending more on health care for their
pets we will also talk about replacing
security guards with a very particular
type of technology and much more david
pakman.com slash membership that is how
you sign up for the bonus show